for many the word city conjures to mind
images of towering skyscrapers and
impressive high-rise skylines in a lot
of parts of the world skyscrapers are
seen as a mark of urban achievement a
way to measure the prosperity of a city
through both the literal and
metaphorical heights it is reached take
a quick glance at most european cities
however and you'll be hard-pressed to
find an example of the towering skylines
that we typically associate with
prosperity even though european cities
consistently dominate the lists of
global cities with the highest quality
of life and highest level of income
their buildings don't seem to reflect
these heights with europe being home to
some of the best known cities in the
world why is it that they lay so low
today we're unpacking the cityscapes of
europe to understand how and why they
have come to be without skyscrapers and
whether or not it's all about to change
a matter of time
it was in the late 19th century when the
interest in building skyscrapers first
rose to prominence primarily in the u.s
cities of chicago and new york by this
time the majority of european cities
were already firmly established with
many already existing as thriving urban
centers for thousands of years while a
great deal of the cities developing in
the usa during this time were the result
of very conscious and calculated urban
planning the layouts of european cities
were produced by centuries upon
centuries of organic urban development
the old age of european cities even in
the 19th century had a great impact on
the availability of plots and land large
enough to support the construction of
these large structures many european
cities still make use of the same narrow
winding streets that have stood since
medieval times making the logistics of
large-scale construction even more
complex than usual while cities in the
u.s were pioneering the project of
high-rise architecture european cities
were largely content to maintain their
centuries-old layouts to complicate
matters even further many european
cities rest on top of what is
essentially marshland making any
large-scale construction particularly
challenging even transit tunnels prove a
tricky project for a lot of cities in
europe as unlike in the us and asia they
cannot be carved out from the ground but
inserted into the earth the soft nature
of european soil and rock bed makes the
deep solid foundations necessary for the
construction of skyscrapers an extra
challenge what's more the cities that
first pioneered high-rise architecture
were experiencing population growth
unprecedented in europe paris for
instance began the year 1880 with a
population of two million two hundred
thousand and thirty years later had
gained around a half a million citizens
for a grand total of two million nine
hundred thousand by comparison in the
same period new york city went from a
population of one million nine hundred
thousand in eighteen hundred to over six
million in nineteen ten with such a
rapid pace of population growth it makes
sense that incorporating high density
living spaces into a cityscape became a
priority associated with the new world
during the time that many cities around
the world began to devote their
attention toward building upwards public
resources in europe were largely focused
elsewhere the first two major waves of
skyscraper construction happened to
coincide with world war one and world
war ii during which almost all european
construction and manufacturing
capabilities were dedicated to the war
effort in fact the unprecedented levels
of destruction caused to the vast
amounts of european urban centers during
the second world war play another role
in why the continent has avoided
building upwards after the war many
expected the land cleared by aerial
attacks and ground fighting to be used
in order to modernize the continent's
old cities and facilitate the
construction of modern skyscrapers
however the great sense of loss and
unfamiliarity caused by the devastation
of the war led to a preference for
rebuilding things as they were before as
opposed to completely reshaping the
landscape cities such as dresden vienna
and warsaw underwent massive
reconstruction efforts in the decades
following the war with great effort to
preserve the cultural heritage that had
been lost regulation
in the 1960s as the focus on post-war
reconstruction faded from priority some
european cities began to dip their toes
into the world of high-rise architecture
in particular the belgian capital of
brussels became the site of a number of
taller developments that took place in
increasingly gentrified neighborhoods
this first began with the city's
preparation for the 1958 world's fair or
expo 58 for which many buildings were
demolished and redeveloped with little
regard to what historical social or
architectural significance they may hold
ambitious building projects began to
sprout up in an effort to rapidly
increase the amount of urban spaces for
living and working as well as streamline
transportation the planning and
development of these high-rises was
altogether less a fair and without
pattern and citizens and public
authorities quickly realized that this
lacks approach to zoning and urban
planning was becoming a problem
throughout the 1970s environmentalists
and preservationists began to lobby the
government with increasing intensity to
do something about the rampant
redevelopment of the city in response
laws were put into place that restrict
the demolition of sites and buildings
that may hold cultural or historical
significance which greatly slowed the
rate of urban redevelopment many other
european cities have adopted similar
policies regarding the protection of
historic buildings most european cities
are home to historic centers and any
plans for urban redevelopment give
priority to the preservation of these
historic quarters the desire to preserve
historic and culturally significant
sections of cities has largely shaped
the european attitude toward their urban
zoning laws zoning
zoning is an approach to urban planning
that practices separating urban areas
into distinct zones each with its own
specific regulations for development the
use of zoning is a method for municipal
authorities to ensure that certain
standards are preserved in different
areas of a city and can be a highly
effective method of making sure that
there is a balance cap between spaces
designed for commercial industrial and
residential purposes zoning laws in
european cities tend to reflect the
emphasis put on a preservation of
historic centers and landmarks and
restrict the building of large modern
projects to specific often outskirted
areas of the city cities such as paris
amsterdam and london have all designated
certain areas of the city in which
high-rise development may take place but
they are confined to spaces that do not
encroach upon the rest of the city
canary wharf in london or la defense in
paris has particularly strong examples
of the effects of zoning restrictions on
the overall city skyline in many
european cities including munich and
groningen historic spires serve as the
limit for how tall any new development
can reach with anything taller being
forced to move outside the city limits
zoning tends to come in one of two forms
single or mixed use single-use zoning is
a practice more common in the usa and is
a method of urban planning that
allocates a particular use for each zone
for example purely residential or purely
industrial in europe however mixed-use
zoning is far more common in which each
zone is intended to fulfill a variety of
urban purposes the consequences of
mixed-use zoning tend to be a more even
scale of development with fewer
differences between the sizes of
residential industrial and commercial
properties this more integrated approach
to urban planning is another major
factor underlying the flatter more even
skylines boasted by most european cities
a matter of mindset of course culture
plays another major role in the lack of
high-rise buildings seen across the
european continent largely speaking the
parts of the world most commonly
associated with skyscrapers like the us
wealthy emirates city-states and asian
mega-cities such as shanghai and tokyo
are technological pioneers that pride
themselves on pushing the boundaries of
expansion it's no coincidence that
skyscrapers emerge from what was known
back then in europe as the new world as
the structures themselves came to
represent striving toward the future
europe at that time especially was more
rooted in historic class consciousness
with a desire to preserve tradition this
priority is reflected in the taste of
modern european architecture with many
viewing skyscrapers and modern buildings
as bland and soulless while the
populations of asia and africa are
booming the population growth of europe
is comparatively petering out with less
of a fervent demand for new residential
and commercial spaces to accommodate
these rapidly increasing populations the
focus of european urban planning has
largely focused on quality over quantity
european cities particularly those in
scandinavia switzerland and western
europe consistently rank among lists of
the best cities to live in the world
they are known for their high living
standards well-connected public
transportation networks and upkeep of
municipal spaces sustainability and the
promotion of urban green spaces are also
of particular importance in most
european cities and keeping construction
projects to a more modest scale lies at
the heart of protecting nature and
encouraging moderation and development
moving forward the attitude toward
high-rise construction has softened in
recent years with the ongoing
globalization of the 21st century and
slowly but surely more developments are
being seen across the european continent
there are now almost 250 buildings
taller than the height of 150 meters or
492 feet in europe yet half of them
belong to just three cities london
moscow and istanbul some skyscrapers
made their way into the eastern european
skylines as a result of the soviet
union's desire to compete with the
achievements of the usa but again this
trend has subsided since the collapse of
the ussr elsewhere across the continent
skyscrapers are generally restricted to
major financial hubs like london and
frankfurt and are rarely seen in smaller
more residential cities whether or not
shifting global trends will give cause
for a change in attitude and lead to an
eventual europe dominated by high-rise
skylines is yet to be seen global
populations continue to shift more
toward urban living as opposed to rural
which is set to have major ramifications
in terms of how cities organize
themselves with this in mind in a world
that is embracing modernity and rapid
development at an even more breakneck
speed the low-lying cityscapes of europe
provide a contrast where plans for the
future are still made with respect for
the past